salve sono brano da quel positivo di mio
fratello ho preso una spesa
con le mie squisite mani per quel covino
zoe ebbene sì e positivo al tampone
vuole fregarmi forse working i porti la
spesa per passarmi skovde
non mi fregherà ai fratello tu quoque
brute tutto o che non mi preghiera i io
ti porterò la spesa ma non mi farò
vedere da te sarko ninja invisibile a te
e al tuo covip
passivo una spesa squisita per un
fratello squisito col compito esclusivo
dello squisito comics così ho sentito
buio al micron al telefono
niente o un ho un appuntamento nel luogo
dove sta facendo la quarantena esso per
portare a quel corridoio squisito una
spesa squisita
sono per lui tanto gli ha fatto comodo a
quella ricerca ovid e chesta quel
fratello nei suoi questo e squisite
maniva una spesa squisita a quel fatelo
ness così top allora sono arrivato a
destinazione
si aggira da queste parti la quale il
piano io lascerò il pacco qui in mezzo
così che quando miglior micron uscirà ci
sarà un contatto sì ma molto sicuro non
verrà mai e quindi io avrà consegnato il
pacco alcuni dovuto
fare cambio di programma lo ior micron è
qui davanti a me non può toccare a il
club
fra spiacente per te una spesa acquisita
well con covic
buon appetito
buongiorno ragazzi una puntata di cucina
buttata covip edition purtroppo se mi
seguite su instagram avete visto che ho
il covip sono positive al covent sono
però piuttosto fortunato perché sento
sapori sento tutto quanto sto di realtà
sto molto molto bene quindi diciamo che
in questo sono stato abbastanza benetto
al signore non sono stato altrettanto
fortunato nella spesa perché rigo ieri
ma ha portato tutto quanto ma ha
sbagliato ogni singolo ingrediente vi
dico solo che io ho detto senti la
scamorza a fette mi raccomando eccola
qua la scamorza affette mi raccomando
belle fette di pane il pancarrè ha
portato delle specie di piccoli
fazzolettini con i vari soffiarvi il
naso perché sto la lattuga va preso tipo
direttamente l'orto che va pulita e
tutto quanto oggi però ho ricevuto un
secondo ordine di poter i cristiani che
si sono sacrificati per portarmi tutto
quello che mi serve
facciamo dei toast che ho già fatto
nelle storie di instagram avete chiesto
di farli anche all'interno di un video
più lungo per spiegare bene procedimento
anche se una cazzata sono quelli che
fanno tipos tic toc sui li fanno ovunque
trovate veramente da ogni parte gli ho
già assaggiati sono buonissimi quindi
direi di partire subito con la ricetta
[Musica]
come vedete non sono la cucina di casa
mia mi dispiace ma la quarantenne dello
iniziata fuori perché ho scoperto essere
positivo fuori casa e
quindi della lince la prima andare bene
di sicuro è meglio di quella topaia
rossa della mia cucina questa qui è
detto ciò partiamo con gli ingredienti
non so come fare liste ministro in un
mondo col cellulare la band
efficacemente così faccio una cosa
diversa ma per fare i toast di tik tok
avremo bisogno di pane in cassetta non
pancarrè raga il pancarrè io non sono
cazzo devi e che ancora si ostinano a
comprare il pancarrè a produrre il
pancarrè le aziende
io lo odio lo tosto e tutto che si
sbriciola una merda il pancarré con un
andiamo avanti scamorza affette e
prosciutto cotto wolf ha la cosa
possibile che non è che ci sono
veramente delle misure dei pesi fate un
po occhio maionese avocado scannerini
pomodoro struttura non potete vedere
lattuga
vabbè sale e semini barbe faccio avere
tutto e quindi ci abbiamo tempo quindi
partiamo subito con la pre preparazione
sembra un bomber che sta che si sta
riprendendo solo è una cosa bellissima
cosa dobbiamo fare e preparati
ingredienti la scamorza e il prosciutto
sono già pronti quello che quindi
dovremmo andare a prepararci alla
postazione sono il pomodoro l'avocado e
l'uovo faccio vedere ragazza la si vede
non solo al caso neanche da lei questa
cassettine di merda io a casa milan
rimossi quindi si vuol dire cosa mi
preme più un caffè lupo di riaverlo
perché pt casa mikhail campioni non si
vede si dorme prendiamo il pomodoro e
ragga cioè davvero non so se tenete sono
la facilità
lattiera lo tagliamo semplice semplice
semplice
raga ma semplice semplice
riscattarlo
semmai una pancia enorme ma anche a voi
di fare sta cosa che quando andate a
tagliare di quel pomodoro altre verdure
frutti tondi e rischia sempre di
scivolare tendenzialmente trasformarvi
in peter minus
fortuna tecnica non bisogna spingere
bisogna fare avanti ha duramente
indietro avanti indietro accarezzando la
superficie finché non entrava solo
faccio vedere
questo è difficile dagli anni difetta
quindi faccio semplicemente
raggiungere l'azienda dell'amante
indietro continente trovati davanti
trovati ecco ora entrato e posso
campiamo andare a talenti un goloso asse
est se una tecnica sicura comunque merda
ma è una ricetta che è una cazzata
buonissima passiamo all avvocato per
l'avvocato ragazzi la tecnica la
conosciamo ormai tutti quanti e le
cazzate ma si chiama tecnica del
cucchiaio tipo quella dei totti però
cedere al volo la tecnica del cucchiaio
per una tecnica base prima di tutto con
un coltello tac è andato di acqua né
oggi né una pensione al cazzo coltello
più grande
ok certo è la ricetta che è una cazzata
bellissima quindi cucchiaio e lo andiamo
a in finale spetta però cedere bene
dentro
due bordi come bordi board e comunque
bordi come se dovessimo
prenderlo in un sol boccone ok
per magia lui
effettivamente si toglierà tutto
intero così è difficilissimo riprenderci
da soli ma anche ricolo dello squisito e
andiamo anche qui a tagliare a
crescentine questo per più facile
per loro è la ricetta che ragazzata e
buonissima
mettiamo da parte il tagliere prendiamo
una ciotola e prepariamo nuovo ria anche
con una ragazzata buffo pack 3 l'uomo è
fondamentale per questa ricetta potete
togliere la carne potete togliere vi
pare ma luogo è fondamentale turno è una
ricetta buona anche vegetariana non so
decana bisognerebbe chiedere ma negano
bravo che riesce mai a trovare delle
alternative un po di sale partiamo
ragazzi partiamo bene rossi farà pratica
con la mente di
marmo bellissimo rosso carbone direi che
ci siamo possiamo accendere i fornelli
non so se mi vedrete scusate mi faccio
aiutare esternamente da altre persone
positive non rivelo di carattere
importante padella grande calda e vi
faccio vedere velocemente perché è un
processo di stime fare abbastanza veloci
1 2 3 e 4 con la scamorza prendiamo
luogo al volo e l'over siamo
a occhio la grande area occhio perché
deve coprire ma della vedete vedete come
come va a coprire
perfettamente tutto quanto prendiamo il
pane e facciamo uno è subito lo giriamo
e 2 e poi questo qui al contrario quindi
con la parte tonda dall'altra parte
e due ci buttiamo dei semini per fare i
figli perché fanno colore belli tutti ci
tagliano le mani sopra
ciao ciao ciao ok lasciato andare con
l'occhio vigile
non dovete poco tenere la faccia almeno
tengo io questa qui è semplicemente
dimostrare che sto sorridendo e che sa
tutto andando bene se volete aiutare
chiudete con un coperchio in modo da
rendere omogenea la parte sotto la parte
sopra anche se sotto sarà sempre un
pochino che bruscolino a questo punto vi
aiutate io mi aiuto con due è giusto
perché sono una schiappa
e comunque anche con noi non ecco e
girate
giriamo testa alta sul mercato e al volo
una fetta di prosciutto su una fetta di
pane una fetta di prosciutto sull'altra
fetta di pane di insalata su una fetta
di pane buona fetta di pomodoro anzi due
fette di pomodoro crepi l'avarizia
dall'altro lato avvocato sbattetelo
felici sorridenti maionese per evitare
di averlo troppo secco non ce la mette
nessuno come salva chiudete chiudete
altra fetta di scamorza e chiudete il
panino
e bellissimo sentire questo pane sentito
lo cantare
mentre faccio andare avanti un altro sul
fuoco passaggio subito questo vi dico
come raccomando ragazzi sky al canale se
lo fate
magari su instagram però sti cazzi fanno
magnate
affolliamo è buonissimo
buona una cazzata è la ricetta che è una
cazzata buonissima salvate in due
secondi mi raccomando fai gli stronzi se
lo fate pagare bisogna star seguito
questo canale seguitemi sinistra che
altrimenti ma non è no affanculo cioè
come fanno tutti quanti senza problemi
c'era una bassa puntata è buttata
sperando di essere finalmente negativo
[Applauso]
[Musica]